[Música]
y
mariupol no se rinde el primer ministro
ucraniano denys 6 miguel sostiene que
los cerca de 3.000 militares que se
refugian en una fábrica de acero
lucharán hasta el final y rusia insiste
que si no deponen las armas los
eliminará
queda exactamente una semana para la
segunda vuelta presidencial en francia
ma jin lepe él se defendió de las
críticas de manuel ma con quien la llamo
escéptica climática mientras los dos
aspirantes mantienen sus diferencias
sobre la política exterior francesa y se
alistan para el único debate
presidencial antes de los comicios
ocho mujeres jóvenes siguen
desaparecidas en la ciudad mexicana de
monterrey y en menos de un mes se han
emitido cerca de 20 denuncias de
desaparición sus familias y
organizaciones de derechos humanos
denuncian que no son hechos aislados
analizaremos en esta emisión
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
los saluda maría clara calle y empezamos
con ucrania los cerca de 2.500 soldados
y 400 mercenarios que rusia dice que
están en una planta de acero en mariupol
continúan sin rendirse mientras que
denny 6 miguel del primer ministro
ucraniano sostiene que ellos lucharán
hasta el final y es que son el último
bastión que tiene ucrania antes de que
la ciudad caiga bajo el control de moscú
el vocero del ministerio de defensa ruso
ígor konashénkov advirtió que quienes
sigan resistiendo serán eliminados les
contamos más en este reporte
se les dio un ultimátum para que
depusieran las armas a cambio de salvar
sus vidas pero las tropas ucranianas que
quedan en la ciudad de mariupol en el
sureste del país han ignorado el plato
del ejército ruso para rendirse y
sostienen que lucharán hasta el final
no la ciudad aún no ha caído todavía
está en nuestras fuerzas militares
nuestros soldados por los que lucharán
hasta el final y por ahora siguen en
mario pool and us for now says you en
mayo el mariupol ha estado sitiada
durante siete semanas y las tropas rusas
afirman que ahora controlan la mayor
parte de la ciudad portuaria los
combatientes ucranianos que quedan se
han refugiado en el distrito industrial
del acero en el laberinto de edificios y
paisajes subterráneos que conforman la
fábrica siderúrgica asusta al cercado
ahora por las fuerzas rusas es el último
gran foco de resistencia en mariupol
los restos del ejército ucraniano y un
gran equipo de civiles están básicamente
rodeados por las fuerzas rusas siguen
luchando pero parece que por la forma en
que el ejército ruso se comporta en
mariupol han decidido arrasar la ciudad
a cualquier precio
en in cost después de su fracaso en la
toma de kiev capturan mariupol sería una
victoria simbólica para moscú los
separatistas creando un corredor
terrestre entre rusia y crimea y
controlando la segunda gran ciudad
ucraniana en caer en manos del kremlin
después de gerson por tercer día
consecutivo hubo bombardeos en harkis la
segunda ciudad más importante de ucrania
el gobierno local afirma que misiles
impactaron en el centro y en el suburbio
de salt ifca al menos cinco personas
murieron y 20 resultaron heridas el
alcalde de la ciudad
igor térek of a vimos que están
evacuando civiles pero reconoció que ya
no hay lugares seguros en kharkiv e
invitó a los ciudadanos a que se vayan
pues siempre me habla
estamos trasladando las personas a
lugares que son menos peligrosos porque
ya no hay lugares completamente seguros
en kharkiv allí proporcionamos un lugar
para vivir comida caliente ducha y ayuda
médica
hago un llamado a todos aquellos que
viven bajo bombardeo interminable para
que se vayan nuestros voluntarios los
ayudarán a hacerlo como
mini pro se ha convertido en una de las
localidades con más centros humanitarios
de ucrania algunos de ellos reciben a
los mas invisibilizados en la guerra las
personas mayores quienes al no poder
valerse por sí mismas quedan solas y
rezagadas ante el éxodo de ciudadanos
que huyen masivamente de las ciudades
asediadas por los rusos melissa chávez
nos cuenta la historia
son los olvidados de la guerra en
ucrania todos los días adultos mayores
llegan a los refugios de vinito estos
centros tienen poco personal y
suministros aquí se encuentran sin
medicación para sus enfermedades
crónicas necesitan ayuda especializada
que muchas veces no está disponible
en estas instalaciones hay más de 130
residentes el 60% son personas de la
tercera edad la infraestructura
anteriormente era una maternidad
abandonada fue reabierta en marzo para
albergar temporalmente a los desplazados
internos todos los trabajadores son
voluntarios
alguien tenía que hacerlo conocemos este
trabajo y cómo organizar todo
correctamente
julia no con la hiena de 83 años llegó
hace semanas huyó de su departamento en
los titanes ya no podía salir por los
bombardeos
si hubiera tenido un pariente cercano
que viviera conmigo me hubiera quedado
prestaba sola por eso tuve que irme la
gran mayoría de adultos mayores
desplazados por la guerra se encuentran
solos solo algunos tienen la suerte de
ser recogidos de estos centros por sus
parientes según las autoridades
ucranianas más de 13.000 personas
mayores o discapacitadas se encuentran
en la región de diestro y más de medio
millón ha pasado por la ciudad desde el
inicio del conflicto el 24 de febrero
queda exactamente una semana para
definir quién será el próximo presidente
de francia el actual mandatario de
manuel ma com aspira a la reelección y
sucre su contrincante en la segunda
vuelta del 24 de abril será la
ultraconservadora + the independent uno
de los puntos que los divide es el medio
ambiente ayer macon señaló que el epen
es una escéptica climática a lo que la
cantidad te respondió hoy que jamás lo
ha sido otra gran diferencia entre los
aspirantes
exterior al punto que el epen ha hecho
propuestas que rompen con el trabajo
internacional tema con los aspirantes al
elíseo defender a sus ideas en el único
debate presidencial que habrá y que se
realizará el próximo miércoles 20 de
abril aquí les explicamos las
diferencias en las relaciones
internacionales
la rusia vladimir putin ha sido durante
mucho tiempo admirada e incluso
cortejada por más de 1.000 p en una
posición muy criticada desde la invasión
rusa de ucrania por lo que la cantidad
de agrupación nacional ha querido dejar
clara su visión se declara partidaria de
reforzar los vínculos entre la otan y
moscú
es tan pronto como la guerra entre rusia
y ucrania haya terminado y tengamos un
tratado de paz lo pondré un acercamiento
estratégico entre la otan y rusia
satiricón soluto en el agua sí
otra medida defendida por marie le pen
la retirada de francia del mando militar
integrado de la otan para recuperar más
soberanía asegura la candidata en
segundo lugar quiere poner fin a la
cooperación industrial con alemania
una posición justificada por los
intereses divergentes entre ambos países
aunque la candidata ya no defiende el
éxito y el abandono del euro sigue
siendo crítica con las limitaciones
impuestas por la legislación europea
una historia totalmente diferente es la
de su rival emanuel mccoy que es
abiertamente pro europeo el presidente
saliente aboga por una unión europea
fuerte y energéticamente independiente
la lucha que estamos librando no es sólo
una lucha por tanto es una lucha por
europa porque el proyecto de
ultraderecha que tenemos delante va en
contra del proyecto que yo defiendo en
nombre de muchos de los que están aquí
es un proyecto oculto ahora es más
ambiguo pero es un proyecto para salir
de europa
después de catalogar como muerte a la
otan en 2019 marco instó a la alianza a
unificarse justificando su decisión por
la guerra que está a las puertas de la
unión europea también pidió que se
aplicaran fuertes sanciones contra moscú
el actual presidente es partidario de la
estabilidad política en tiempos de
crisis una estabilidad que pretende
encarnar vamos a eeuu los jóvenes
murieron y 11 más resultaron heridos
luego de un tiroteo en una fiesta
nocturna en pittsburgh el departamento
de policía de la ciudad detalló que los
primeros disparos se escucharon a las 12
30 de la madrugada la policía cree que
hubo múltiples tiradores y encontraron
casquillos de pistolas y de un rifle la
investigación preliminar habla de que
hubo al menos 50 disparos en la fiesta
donde había más de 200 personas este es
el cuarto tiroteo masivo que ocurre en
la última semana en eeuu
y al menos ocho mujeres siguen
desaparecidas en la zona metropolitana
de monterrey en méxico en el último mes
se han hecho entre 19 y 22 denuncias de
desaparición de jóvenes que tienen entre
12 y 26 años sus familias denuncian
deficiencias en la investigación y
afirman que no son hechos aislados para
hablar de este tema vamos hasta pachuca
dónde está marta canseco ella es
periodista y activista por los derechos
humanos de las mujeres bienvenidas a
france 24 señora canseco explíquenos a
qué se debe esta ola de desapariciones
en monterrey muy buenas noches maría
clara mira decirte que en mexico
desaparecen al día 7 mujeres en nuestro
país son las que las que queda registro
pero el número es mayor evidentemente en
los en lo que va del año del 1 de enero
al 14 de abril han desaparecido en
nuestro país
748 mujeres
55 de ellas en el nuevo léon no
solamente en la ciudad de monterrey que
es la capital sino en nuevo león
el estado la característica que tiene
nueva leones que hace frontera con texas
y entonces pues evidentemente es mucho
más fácil sacarlas de el país los
estados con mayor número de mujeres
desaparecidas es así mira es estado de
méxico ciudad de méxico monterrey este
perdón morelos y en cuarto lugar nuevo
león el problema se está agudizando y
evidentemente no ayuda mucho la posición
del gobierno al respecto dice que es
normal al gobierno mexicano le parece
normal que siete mujeres al día
desaparezcan en nuestro país ahora dice
que están trabajando al respecto pero no
terminan de decirnos cómo es que están
trabajando recordar también mar y aclara
que en el en el estado de nuevo léon no
hay una ley contra trata y el principal
la principal cantidad de mujeres que
están desapareciendo desde los 15 a los
19 años lo que habla por supuesto de un
fenómeno de trata en esa zona y este
estado no tiene ninguna ley que prevenga
ni castigue
y porque los organismos de derechos
humanos dicen que estas desapariciones
en el estado de nuevo león no son
aisladas
porque se viene incrementando
desde hace 10 años por la presencia del
crimen organizado y no solamente la
presencia del crimen organizado
maría clara sino la colusión que hay con
autoridades de todos los niveles con las
policías estatales y municipales con las
con la guardia nacional e ike y también
por supuesto y en colombia lo vivieron
por ejemplo la militarización de
los militares en labores de guardia y
custodia de la de la población no
entonces eso sí también aumenta esta
situación por eso se dice que no son
casos aislados
evidentemente 6 claro claro es culpable
en el ángelus o lo quiero hacer la
última pregunta la desaparición de the
one y escobar y el feminicidio de maria
fernanda contreras despertaron la
indignación en méxico muy brevemente que
les pasó a ellas
bueno en el caso de maría fernanda fue a
una reunión hay un amigo de ella le pide
que lo lleve a comprar un vehículo
van a casa de él y ahí no se sabe
todavía no ha querido dar declaración la
mata de golpes en la cabeza
ese es el caso específico de amina
fernanda de de bani de baní fue a una
fiesta con unas amigas se pusieron de
acuerdo y ahí se quedó lo que acordaron
las amigas fue llamar a un auto con un
nuevo cita debe interrumpir para exhibir
marc con el noticiero gracias por estar
con nosotros gracias gracias mariana y
pasamos a otras noticias porque ya los
buzos inspeccionan el casco del buque
que se hundió con 750 toneladas de
combustible en las costas de túnez las
autoridades intentan minimizar la
posibilidad de un derrame y el ejército
selló el golfo de gabes donde naufragó
la embarcación
flotando la superficie un fragmento del
mástil es todo lo que se ve del
petrolero sé lo que es un día 20 metros
de profundidad en aguas tunecinas las
autoridades dicen que su carga 750
toneladas de diésel no presenta escapes
ni daños
a los buzos de la marina examinaron la
zona y confirmaron que no hay ninguna
fuga
todos los depósitos de diésel están
intactos
oficiales están ahora a la espera de la
opinión de los expertos para determinar
cómo extraer el combustible se han
ubicado 200 metros de barreras de
protección contra el petróleo en
previsión de una fuga algo que preocupa
a los ciudadanos de gabes durante años
la población ha sufrido la contaminación
marina provocada por los residuos de un
complejo industrial cercano
al malki metros y estamos al lado del
grupo químico tunecino una empresa
pública que como se puede ver aquí
excava fosfoyesos directamente en el mar
se vierten toneladas y toneladas cada
año en el hundimiento del barco de
combustible todo el mundo habla ahora de
proteger el mar pero basta con ver cómo
el estado tunecino lleva décadas
contaminando lo en esta playa de la
ciudad es raro ver a los pescadores una
vez más debido a la contaminación
desde el comienzo del ramadán solo he
trabajado dos días si el tiempo es malo
pero aparte de eso cuando sales al mar
ya no encuentras peces solo plantas
según un informe de la comisión europea
la región de gabes pierde 24 millones de
euros al año por el deterioro de su
medio ambiente y el 47 por ciento de esa
pérdida está relacionada con la pesca
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con
nosotros
[Música]